oh
hello
you ready to get cold i'm ready to get
cold luke here at the outdoor boys
youtube channel and i'm here with my
sister michelle and we're going camping
above the arctic circle are you ready
michelle i hope yeah i'm ready
let's do this
[Music]
well guys it is a chilly seven degrees
here in alaska and i'm here with my
oldest sister michelle who absolutely
hates the cold
isn't that right michelle
it's tough it's tough but i'm always
looking for challenges so we are gonna
see if we can't take michelle camping
above the arctic circle in the dead of
winter and keep her warm and have a good
time
or we're gonna die trying right we're
gonna die
look michelle moose we're seeing booze
we've seen three moves so far
moose michelle there's three moves out
there look at that they're so cute
that's a total of six moves on this trip
i need a moose counter on the bottom of
the screen
welcome to denali national park
it looks like every other spot in alaska
only you're not allowed to shoot stuff
well michelle welcome to healy we know
somebody who got in the gun fight at
healey you know that
it's a little bit bumpy because we're
driving on a sheet of ice
the ice has a hole in it a gap in it
going over these little gaps every you
know 30 feet or so
it's fun
road conditions make drinking
challenging
all right michelle welcome to the city
of nana
this is where the nana ice classic
happens so they got this big tower here
and they take it out onto the frozen
river and they tie a rope to the top and
the rope goes over there to that tower
to a stopwatch and a bell and when you
buy tickets to the banana ice classic
you predict the day the hour the minute
you think that tower is going to fall
through the ice comes springtime and
whoever guesses closest goes and wins
the whole pool so 2021 was actually the
100th year anniversary of the banana ice
classic it's been going since
1921 all right michelle welcome to fox
alaska our last bit of civilization on
this trip don't tell me that
here's a campground here that we're
thinking about stopping for the
nice yeah
oh i think it's right over there on the
other side of that five-foot snowboard
i didn't want to get out of the cold car
anyway how about you michelle
apparently not so we're gonna move
forward and we're gonna have to drive
into the night a bit uh but we're gonna
make better time getting to where we
wanted to go and uh we'll see what the
yukon river looks like we might be able
to camp on the yukon river
kevin we're on the dalton highway woo
this is hardcore michelle i know i just
didn't do it
all right michelle we're here at the
yukon river
we're here at the only gas pump between
fox and the arctic circle
and uh one of the only buildings between
fox and the arctic circle
when i was engaged to my wife i actually
spent five weeks living north of here
along the side of the road with a
construction crew and i used to have to
come down here to get gas all the time
in case you don't get enough
well check it out this is the lodge here
at the yukon camp and they've got uh
rooms to stay at and they have one
available so i think i'm gonna grab that
because i don't feel like setting up the
tent in the dark and in the snow at
negative 11. so we're going to wuss out
tonight so that we're nice and fresh for
tomorrow
[Music]
in front of each of these parking spots
they have a 120 volt outlet so you can
go ahead and plug in your oil pan
heaters to keep your cars from freezing
overnight all right let's check out our
room
hey michelle
oh this is nice
[Applause]
we're here at the yukon river camp
common room here and uh we're gonna make
a little dinner
[Music]
my ventilation system is working very
well
all right
philly cheesesteak sandwiches
just gonna cook these over a campfire
tonight but you know you got to be
adaptable when you're in alaska
best philly cheesesteak north of yukon
right here
so right now we are on the banks of the
yukon river here at the yukon river camp
and we've got about
two and a half three hour drive to the
arctic circle tomorrow so we are in easy
striking distance of our campsite for
tomorrow so this will be nice
good morning i sure hope the truck's
gonna start
sorry
good morning michelle oh yes good
morning luke
all right i just leave actually pretty
good pretty good i'm a little cold but
i'm doing all right i think we need to
do something about breakfast
i'm making this whole place smell like
bacon i think it's good that we're the
only ones here
looks like we're getting a little bit of
sunlight
that's the alaska pipeline right there
well now that we can see outside i think
it's time to get this party on the road
it seems like i've actually been more
hot
all right here we go
you know one thing we got to do before
we get out of here michelle we got to
show you the yukon river yes
wow
all right we are properly on top of the
yukon
there's a couple villages along the
banks of the river upstream and
downstream so when it freezes
they can go and take snow machines and
dog sleds here to the road system and
everything my face is pulled down yeah
my ears are fine
all over my face too oh my god i
shouldn't have worn the glasses because
yeah the rooms your glasses get so cold
then it's the metal against your ear
yeah check it out we got the alaska
pipeline goes all the way from prudo bay
to valdez and uh this road follows right
alongside it i dare you to lick it
[Music]
this is the arctic circle
we gotta stand in front of the sign
the arctic circle is the lowest latitude
at which in the winter time you can have
a point where the sun doesn't rise and
at a point in the summer when the sun
doesn't set there you go guys arctic
circle
latitude 66 degrees 33 minutes
oh i can't touch it my fingers so all
right guys from this point anything
north is in the arctic circle and we are
gonna be camping in the arctic circle
this is your first winter camping trip
isn't it yes let's see
all right we're gonna drive a little bit
north and look for a campsite and you
may not believe this but there's not a
lot of campgrounds open in the
wintertime in the arctic circle so
we're gonna have to kind of find our own
spot here
one of these semi trucks pass you can't
see anything
look at this
i think it's time to do a little digging
here
am i exhausted
and start clipping your way up
further to the back
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
let's make this unnecessarily
complicated this is fatwood you smell it
it's got a strong pine smell to it yeah
when a pine tree dies all the resin
drains down to the stump chop up the
stuff and it's full of this flammable
pine tar and so it makes a good fire
start take my tin
there we go
hey let it get going really
getting your nice warm home going out in
the woods i supposed to
keep all of our fire starting stuff
under the bed in case the fire goes out
in the night
stuff is less important
all right we're going ahead and melt
some snow there i'm gonna grab more oh
it's toasty in here you like that yeah i
like that i think i could do this yeah
it's gonna be okay anything i'm gonna
keep warm put on the clothesline and
it'll be extra toasty up there my gloves
got a little wet so we're gonna just
throw those up there and they'll dry in
about 20 minutes whew it's uh it's
t-shirt weather here on the arctic
circle
whoa it's it's
it's hot all right it's hot i'm gonna
show you hungry
all right would you like some beef
stroganoff on rice sounds good to me all
right let's do it
here we put some rice in there we got
olive oil and diced onions here
they did have mongolian no sense in
taking stuff back home right we gotta
let's use this up
all right got some heavy whipping cream
here okay i forgot
this looks delicious what do you think
smell good
it smells delicious
awesome
that's not awkward just pretend the
camera is not
not too bad huh it was delicious it's
low calorie it's diet
wow we
we just finished dinner and it's getting
kind of quiet we just heard a wolf house
it was a wolf house
yeah it didn't sound that far away i
guess but it was down near 10 and also
oh there it is
yeah it's coming from that way yeah
[Music]
oh gosh
that is totally a wolf it's only four
o'clock and the sun's already set we've
already eaten our first dinner so i'm
just gonna work on a little carving
project here
[Music]
so
[Music]
nice little piece of uh sitka cedar
right there little yellow sticky yellow
cedar yeah
it's so it looks soft and just there we
go i haven't done any wood carving in a
long time so this is a nice little uh
way to get the rust off but fun little
project
made a nice little mess of my caribou
hide there it's time for second dinner
second dinner is a real thing in winter
camping
we ate at three so you know michelle you
need second dinner
i'm good
well it's getting late and i'm getting
ready for bed and i'm gonna do something
i wanna do for a while i'm gonna set up
a time lapse we might see the northern
lights tonight and uh might see some
beautiful stars it's just
it's gorgeous outside and i want to show
you but um the cold weather absolutely
tanks gopro batteries so you can't just
you know set up a time lapse and a
camera outside so what i'm going to do
is i've got an external battery and i'm
going to put a bunch of adhesive hand
warmers on this and this
will give me about 10 times the normal
life of a gopro battery and then by
putting hand warmers on it and shoving
it inside a glove or something i can
hopefully keep this warm enough where
this will run all night and we can uh
see the beautiful sky tonight oh it is
pretty
look at that moon
all right guys it's getting late i'm
getting ready for bed i'm going to show
you one of my secrets to keeping my feet
warm in my sleeping bag down booties you
can wear them like slippers in your tent
or wear them in your sleeping bag and
they are great for keeping your feet
warm so i got michelle hooked up with uh
becca's pair of down booties there we're
gonna see if they do the truck all right
guys it's late i'm going to bed enjoy
the time lapse i'll see you guys in the
morning
[Music]
oh
well good morning it's about seven a.m
and
it's cold in here we let the fire go out
completely
but uh
uh i'm warm
you in there michelle
yeah
the michelle is a very solitary creature
wait she emerges from work
breathe on you if you don't stop
all right you've completed your first
night of winter camping you've slept in
the arctic
how you feeling i'm feeling pretty good
actually i i did i did actually
fairly well the bag is
wide and comfortable so i could curl up
well it's only a.m so we've got about a
good three hours before the sun's up so
we're gonna kind of take it easy uh do
the slow cleanup get some breakfast
going
all right we got a scotch egg that
michelle kindly made for us we're gonna
warm it up right there
i don't know sometimes
keeps people more honest because you
know
the thing i i do every time
i i would yeah scotched egg chocolate
brioche toast some eggs bacon
well it's almost nine o'clock and we
have a long trip home so uh we're gonna
start packing up and getting things
going and we're gonna try to get out of
here around the time the sun comes up
[Music]
[Music]
there's fire in the fireplace anyways
right
[Applause]
there's something immensely satisfying
about seeing the big warm clear spot
where the tent used to be
this is a cool camp spot
well listen guys we're all packed up
it's a quarter past 10 and we are just
barely seeing the light come up over the
horizon we have about 13 14 hour drive
home so i think uh we better hit the
road we end up letting the car run all
night last night and uh worked out
pretty good we only used about two
gallons of gas doing that so
seems like that was the right choice to
make
the truck's a little frozen ground
didn't want to let go of the tires there
guys check it out the snow is so deep
here
look at this
the snow is so crazy deep here
but it is so pretty
we didn't see us on the way up because
it was so dark
there's a snow rainbow up ahead it's
basically a rainbow but it's caused by
snow instead of rain it actually would
be a snowball
a snowball i guess that's right it's a
snowboat
we just saw two more moose that's eight
another moose
that's number nine
well michelle we made it back safe and
sound did you have fun it was so fun oh
good well i hope you guys enjoyed
watching this as much as we enjoyed
filming it
we drove 1100 miles in three days we
camped on the arctic circle we heard
wolves it was a great time
if you guys want to see more videos from
the outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every saturday morning and check
out our camping adventure playlist i'll
put a link in the video description
below we have over 60 videos with
camping adventures all over the world
thanks for watching guys
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]